Sal: I want to make a quick
correction to my second
oxidation video.
It was pointed out that I made
an error that you will
probably find confusing.
So I had written down
hydrogen peroxide.
Because this was one of the
situations or the special
cases where oxygen's oxidation
state isn't
necessarily minus 2.
So hydrogen peroxide is 2
hydrogens, 2 oxygens.
And it's structure
looks like this.
The oxygens are bonded to each
other, and they're each bonded
to a hydrogen.
And we know oxygen is really
electronegative.
It likes to hog electrons.
And I said that in that video.
And because it hogs electrons,
the hydrogens lose their
electron to oxygen, or at least
from the oxidation state
point of view.
So they each have a plus 1
oxidation state, which I did
say in that video.
And then I went on and my brain
was clearly-- and this
is actually a good point for you
to realize how confusing
this can sometimes
be if you're not
careful with your work.
I say in the last video,
and obviously
oxygen gains an electron.
And then I say and it's
oxidation state is plus 1.
Which clearly makes no sense.
If you gain an electron,
that will reduce
your oxidation state.
It will reduce that hypothetical
charge.
And so your oxidation
state is minus 1 in
each of these oxygens.
And, of course, this is
a special case because
traditionally, oxygen in
the case I always show
it with, is in water.
When it takes 2 electrons, 1
from this hydrogen and 1 from
that hydrogen, it normally has
an oxidation state of minus 2
and, of course, in this case,
it's plus 1 and plus 1 for the
2 hydrogens.
I think later, when I go back
to the molecular formula, I
kind of corrected in my head.
But I want to be very
clear to you.
Oxygen does not have an
oxidation state of plus 1 in
hydrogen peroxide.
It is minus 1.
I said it gained the electrons,
but then my brain
obviously heard the word gaining
and wanted to put a
plus sign there.
No.
it gained an electron that
reduces the oxygen.
It makes its oxidation state
minus 1 for hydrogen peroxide.
So hydrogen peroxide has 2
hydrogens with a plus 1
oxidation state.
And it has 2 oxygens with a
minus 1 oxidation state.
One times 2 minus 1 times 2 is
equal to 0, so we're all cool.